[Music]
a lone priestess walks towards an
underground chamber people line the
streets to watch as she proclaims her
innocence
it doesn't matter she's already been
judged and found guilty the sentence
live burial the underground chamber
contains a portion of bread water milk
and oil she will have a lamp a bed and a
blanket but she won't emerge alive at
the threshold
the priestess pauses claims her
innocence one last time then enters the
chamber never to be seen again by the
Roman people the priestess is one of
Rome's six Vestal Virgins each carefully
selected as children from Rome's most
aristocratic families but now with her
death there are only five and a new
priestess must be chosen the
six-year-old lakenya witnessed the
spectacle never suspecting that a few
days later she'd be chosen as the next
vestal virgin her age her patrician
family lineage and her apparent good
health makes her the best candidate to
serve the goddess Vesta in the eyes of
the Romans
her parents are proud that their
daughter has been chosen the Kenya is
afraid but she has no choice in the
matter
she must serve the goddess for at least
the next thirty years for the first ten
years of lakenya's service she's
considered in training learning how to
be a vestal virgin her most important
duty is keeping vigil over the flame of
Vesta the virgin goddess of the hearth
Vesta doesn't have a statue like other
Roman gods and goddesses instead she's
represented by the flame which burns day
and night in her temple located next to
the Forum in the centre of the city
like all Vestal priestesses lakenya
spends part of each day on shift
watching and tending to the flame the
flame represents two things the first is
the continuation of Rome as a power in
the world
the Romans believed that if the flame
goes out the cities in danger the flame
also symbolizes the continuing virginity
of Vestas priestesses for the Romans a
Vestals virginity signal not only hircus
teeta's or modest spirit and body but
also her ritual purity so lakenya knows
she must never let the flame go out her
life the lives of her fellow Vestals
and the safety of Rome itself depends
upon it Laconia learns to collect water
each day from a nearby fountain to
cleanse the temple she learns the fasty
the calendar of sacred rituals and she
watches while the senior priestesses
conduct sacrifices by the time Laconia
completes her training she's 16 years
old
lakenya understands that the way she
must act is a reflection of the goddess
she serves when it's her turn to collect
the water she keeps her eyes lowered to
the ground when she performs sacrifices
she focuses intently on the task
lakenya directs her energy towards being
the best priestess she can be she's
worried that someday the state will
claim her life for its own purposes to
protect itself from danger lakenya could
be accused of in custom meaning
unchastity at any time and be sacrificed
whether she's innocent or guilty
lakenya fully understands now why her
predecessor was buried alive 10 years
ago
the flame of Vesta went out the
priestesses knew that they couldn't keep
it a secret the future of Rome depended
upon it they went to the chief priests
and he opened an investigation to
discover why the flame had failed
someone came forward and claimed that
one of the Vestals was no longer a
virgin that was the beginning of the end
the accused protested her innocence but
it wasn't enough she was tried and found
guilty
that Vestals death was meant to protect
the city but lakenya weeps for what has
been lost and for what she knows now her
own path was paved by the death of
another and her life could be taken just
as easily for something as simple as a
flame going out
[Music]
you